some very strange wire transfers have
been uncovered from the Russian Foreign
Ministry through a Kremlin backed and
sanctioned bank called VTB Bank to
Russian embassies around the world
including in Washington DC and what
strange isn't so much that transfers
themselves each of which refer many tens
of thousands of dollars
totaling somewhere around 380 or 400
thousand dollars but the memo lines on
some of these transfers which said to
finance election campaign of 2016 the
Russian foreign embassies sent money to
finance the election campaign of 2016 to
a number of different embassies around
the world including in the United States
about 60 such wire transfers were made
and are being looked at by the FBI in
total as I said about four hundred
thousand dollars were moved through city
bank accounts and other bank accounts
around the world and the what's not
clear here and I want to be super clear
I'm not saying that these transfers were
for helping Donald Trump win in the u.s.
there's a couple reasons why that
doesn't make sense number one $380,000
is nothing when you consider the amount
of money that it takes to influence an
American presidential election that's
number one number two the memos say for
financing the 2016 election camp
campaign it doesn't say US presidential
election it doesn't even say election in
the US could have been in any country
and indeed similar payments were made to
many many countries around the world but
of course when you have three
investigations into possible Russian
influence of our election and collusion
with Donald Trump and our own Director
of National Intelligence said in January
that Vladimir Putin had personally
signed off on an influencer campaign to
help Donald Trump of course we would
want to know whether this money was for
helping the election of Donald Trump in
the United States but again 380,000
dollars even if it was somehow to help
get Trump elected it's basically a
meaningless amount of money and where it
really gets interesting is not the
amount of money or the embassy it's the
connections the coincidences the Russian
bank that the money came through
VTB Bank that is a bank that is
sanctioned by the United States that is
the same bank that Felix aider was
looking to use to make a deal to finance
Trump Tower Moscow and Felix Seder is
the guy who we now know wrote an email
to a trump campaign official saying I
will get Putin on this program and we
will get Donald Trump elected so is the
380,000 dollars some kind of smoking gun
that we've been waiting for of course
not it's not enough money the memos
could be referring to any election but
again when you take it all together the
connection to VTB Bank
Felix Sater the timing none of it points
to nothing to see here
all of it points to many more things to
investigate and of course the Russia
dossier we get closer to another element
of the Russia dossier being confirmed
the Russia dossier claimed and you might
remember this from when we initially
reviewed it that the mechanism for
transmitting this intelligence involves
pension disbursements to russian émigré
living in the u.s. as cover using
consular officials in New York DC and
Miami this isn't exactly what the Russia
dossier is alleging these payments that
were circulating and going into
embassies but it's certainly possible
that these payments that we've
identified might have been payments for
covert operatives working on the behalf
of Russia in these countries and that
would not be something that is unique to
Russia by no means okay many countries
do this many countries use these types
of transfers to pay for people that are
working as agents or providing
intelligence for them so no smoking gun
but yet more issues to look at and
certainly robert muller is looking at
them that we can be sure of the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad